[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جم
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من غازي عنتاب جنوبي
تركيا حيث يتواصل التحقيق مع المشتبه في
ضلوعهم في عدم مطابقه المعايير الفنيه
المعمول بها في اقامه مباني مقاومه
للزلازل
وثياب هذه الصور من هناك حيث ما زالت
الصفارات الانذار في دوري من حين الى اخر
ايذانا بخطر محتمل في مطلع عام جديد من
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا بينما تبذل جهود
لانشاء محكمه لجرائم الحرب في البلاد
ومن ابوجع عاصمه نيجيريا اكبر بلد في
افريقيا من حيث عدد السكان تصلنا هذه
الصور في يوم كان فيه 94 مليون ناخذ
مدعوين للتصويت في انتخابات رئاسيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
اجتماع بالعقبه اليوم الاحد يضم مسؤولين
سياسيين وامنيين فلسطينيين واسرائيليين
الى جانب الاردن ومصر والولايات المتحده
مسؤول فلسطينيه يقول للجزيره ان اللقاء
يهدف لضمان وقف اجراءات اسرائيل الاحاديه
فصائل المقاومه في جنين تقول انه سيمنح
الاحتلال فرصا لارتكاب مزيد من الجرائم
والفصائل بغزه تحذر وتقول ان المشاركين
خارجون عن الاجماع الوطني
حمله الاعتقالات تتصاعد في تونس مثيره
مزيدا من الاسئله
حبس خمسه موقوفين من الشخصيات السياسيه
المعارضه على ذمه التحقيق فريق الدفاع
يقاطع جلسه المرافعه بسبب ما اعتبره غيابا
لشروط محاكمه عادله وقوى سياسيه تصف
الاعتقالات بمحاوله لتصفيه الخصوم
[موسيقى]
عاشر حزمه عقوبات اوروبيه على روسيا مع
دخول الحرب عامها الثاني الاتحاد الاوروبي
يصفها بالاوسع نطاقا ويحذر حلفاء موسكو
الصين تعرقل اقرار بيان ختامي الاجتماعي
وزراء ماليه العشرين حول اوكرانيا
ومظاهرات في برلين وباريس للاحتجاج على
تزويد كييف بالاسلحه وللمطالبه بارساء
السلام في اوكرانيا
اكثر من خمسين الف قتيل ضحايا زلزاليه
تركيا وسوريا وبعد تضرر اكثر من 160 الف
مبنى في مدن تركيا عده انقره توسع التحقيق
في الانهيارات اعتقال اكثر من 180 شخصا
وملاحقات قضائيه تشمل 600 شخص
وضعف الامكانات يقوض جهود الاغاثه في شمال
سوريا والمنظمات المحليه تحصي مئات الالاف
دون ماوى
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه
ناقشنا ادانه الاتحاد الافريقي مواقف
الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد بشان المهاجرين
من افريقيا جنوب الصحراء ودعوته الى
الامتناع عن اي خطاب كراهيه له طابع عنصري
قد يلحق الضرر لاشخاص
رفضت وزاره الخارجيه التونسيه هذه الادانه
وقالت ان الاتهامات لا اساس لها من الصحه
وكان سعيد قد دعى الى اجراءات عاجله لوقف
تدفق المهاجرين من افريقيا جنوب الصحراء
معتبرا وجودهم في تونس جزءا من مؤامره
تهدف لتغيير التركيبه السكانيه للبلاد
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم ما
ابعاد اثاره قضيه المهاجرين الافارقه في
تونس
46% قالوا ان الهدف هو توظيف الموضوع من
السلطه في ضوء الازمه الداخليه بينما ادرج
19% المساله في اطار توجه رسمي لتقليص
وجود المهاجرين الافارقه في البلاد وربط
خمسه وثلاثون في المئه بين اثاره القضيه
والبحث عن دعم دولي لصد الهجره غير
النظاميه هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت
عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجد ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
وسط تحديات امنيه واقتصاديا انتخابات
رئاسيه في نيجيريا البلد الاكبر في
افريقيا من حيث عدد السكان
[موسيقى]
يؤخذ غدا في مدينه العقبه الاردنيه مؤتمر
امني يجمع وفدا من السلطه الفلسطينيه
واسرائيل
بمشاركه مسؤولين امنيين من الولايات
المتحده والاردن ومصر وقال مسؤول فلسطيني
كبير للجزيره ان الاجتماع يهدف لتحقيق
تفاهمات حول فتره انتقاليه تضمن وقت
اسرائيل الاجراءات الاحاديه من استيطان
وهدم واقتحامات لمده سته اشهر يتم خلالها
التحضير لتهدئه والانتقال الى مسار اكثر
اتساعا اضاف المسؤول الفلسطينيه ان
اسرائيل رفضت مشاركه اطراف عربيه اخرى ادت
استعدادها لذلك واشار المسؤول الى ان
الاردن ومصر والولايات المتحده تبذل قصار
جهدها لمنع انفجار الاوضاع خلال شهر رمضان
اعياد اليهوديه في مارس المقبل
من جانبها استنكرت فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في غزه مشاركه السلطه
الفلسطينيه في الاجتماع الامني المزمع
عقده غدا في مدينه العقبه الاردنيه
واعتبرت في بيان لها ان مشاركه السلطه
الفلسطينيه طعنه جديده لتضحيات الشعب
الفلسطيني وخيانه لتضحيات الشهداء وحذرت
فصائل المقاومه من خطوره اجتماع العقبه
وقالت انه استكمال لمخططات التامر على شعب
الفلسطيني وقضيته ومحاوله جديده لاستئصال
مشروع المقاومه واضاف البيان ان المشاركين
في هذا الاجتماع خارجون عن الاجماع الوطني
ولا يمثلون الا انفسهم
وقالت الاذرع العسكريه التاليه عليه فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في مخيم جنين ان
اجتماع عقب الامني غدا لا يصب في خدمه
الشعب الفلسطيني بل يمثل خدمه مجانيه
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي واستنكرت فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه مشاركه السلطه
الفلسطينيه في الاجتماع وقالت ان هذه
المشاركه تاتي في اتجاه معاكس
للاجماع الوطني الرافضي لها
ان هذا اللقاء لا يصب في مصلحه شعبنا
بل يمثل خدمه مجانيه
للاحتلال الصهيوني المجرم الذي لا يتوقف
عن العدوان على شعبنا وارضنا ومقدساتنا
ان مشاركه السلطه الفلسطينيه في هذا
اللقاء تاتي في اتجاه المعاكس
للاجماع الوطني الرافض لهذا اللقاء
والمطالب بالغائه
فالغاء هذا اللقاء هو اضعف قرار يمكن ان
تتخذه السلطه
كرد على جرائم حكومه الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
معنى من غزه مصطفى صواف الكاتب والمحلله
سياسي ومن رام الله محمد هواش الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي ابدا معك سيد محمد هواش
ماذا ستستفيد السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
من المشاركه في هذا الاجتماع وما هو
المقابل اذا كان الهدف كما يقول مسؤول
فلسطيني وقف اسرائيل للاجراءات الاحاديه
ما المقابل الذي ستقدمه السلطه لاسرائيل
مساء الخير لك
وللساده المشاهدين
اولا يعني هذا اللقاء هو فرصه لاختبار
النوايا نوايا اسرائيل كانت هناك محاولات
دوليه ومحاولات يعني عربيه
يعني التوصل الى تفاهمات توقف اسرائيل من
خلالها كل اشكال عدوان على الشعب
الفلسطيني بما في ذلك وقف انتهاكات يعني
اقتحامات المدن الفلسطينيه ووقف عمليات
القتل في الشوارع ووقف عمليات التطهير
العرقي والاستيطان وكل يعني اشكال
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه اليوميه لحقوق
الشعب الفلسطيني كانت هناك محاولات ولا
يوجد ثقه حتى الان لا يوجد ثقه بان الجانب
الاسرائيلي يريد تفاهمات ويريد وقف هذه
الانتهاكات وبالتالي وبالتالي هناك ضغوط
عربيه ودوليه على الفلسطينيين وعلى
الاسرائيليين ان يذهبوا الى اللقاء مجرد
لقاء لاخت النوايا نحن لا نثق على الاطلاق
بالاسرائيليين لان السلوك الاسرائيلي على
الارض مخالف لكل يعني التعهدات مخالف لكل
لكن وجود ولكن مقابل ماذا فقط يعني انا
كان سؤالي اوضح من ذلك مقابل ماذا ستوقف
اسرائيل
اجراءاتها الاحاديه من استيطان واقتحامات
ماذا ستقدم السلطه في المقابل لا مقابل لا
مقابل لهذه الانتهاكات لان اسرائيل تنتهك
يعني الحقوق الوطنيه الفلسطينيه تنتهك
القانون الدولي يجب وقف انتهاكات اسرائيل
لحقوق الفلسطينيين اليوميه بدون مقابل هذا
ما يفرضه القانون الدولي ما يفرضه وهل
اسرائيل اسرائيل ذاهبه الى اجتماع العقبه
لكي تعطي هذا الامر بالمجان
نعم نعم هي هي مفترض ان ان تريد تهدئه في
كل تهدئه فلسطينيه فقط ولكن الفلسطينيون
ايضا يريدون وقف الانتهاكات اليوميه
الاسرائيليه للشعب الفلسطيني ويذهبون
ويذهبون الى كل لقاء وكل اجتماع يمكن ان
يفضي ولو بامل بسيط جدا ان يفضي الى وقف
هذه الانتهاكات اليوميه للحقوق الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه لحقوق المواطن الفلسطيني في كل
مدينه فلسطينيه وفي كل شارع وفي كل طريق
ايضا هناك
اين المشكله لماذا الفصائل
ترفض هذا الاجتماع اذا كان هو مجرد اختبار
لنوايا اسرائيل وهو البحث في وقت
الاستيطان والاقتحامات وغير ذلك من دون اي
مقابل اذا المساله هي قد تعطي اسرائيل هذا
الامر بالمجان لماذا
لا تذهب بالسلطه الى اجتماع من هذا النوع
ومن قال لك ان السلطه او ان الكيان
الصهيون يمكن ان يعطي سلطه ما تريد دون ان
يكون هناك ثمن وقال الكل يعلم ان هذا
اللقاء الامني الهدف منه هو وقف المقاومه
في الضفه الغربيه خاصه وفي القدس لان
الشهر الذي
قريب جدا سيكون شهر رمضان والاحتلال يخشى
من تصاعد المقاومه في شهر رمضان لذلك كل
هذه الجهود الامريكيه والمصريه والاردنيه
والصهيونيه تهدف الى وقف المقاومه واعتقد
لو ان هناك عاقلا في السلطه الفلسطينيه
لربما استمع الى ما قام به المواطنون
الليل الماضيه من الاستجابه لنداء فقط
مجموعه مسلحه اسمها عرين الاسود وخرج الى
الشوارع في كل المدن الضفه الغربيه وقطاع
غزه ليردد الله اكبر هذا هو الشعب
الفلسطيني الذي يعني عندما تقول الهدف
الاجتماع مقاومه عفوا عندما تقول الهدف من
الاجتماع وقف المقاومه من الذي سيوقف
المقاومه يعني كيف يكون الهدف من الاجتماع
وقف المقاومه نعم كيف
يا سيدي اعتقد ان لدى السلطه من الوسائل
ما يمكن من خلاله ملاحقه المقاومه واعتقال
للمقاومين ومصادره اسلحتهم وهناك كثير من
الدلائل على ارض الواقع في الضفه الغربيه
اشارت الى ذلك وعلى راسهم على سبيل المثال
مصعب اشتهيه الذي لا زال وله اكثر من 160
يوم داخل معتقلات اريحا والتعاون الامني
القائم الان وعلى اشده حتى في ظل عدم
استجابه الاحتلال لاي مطالب على سبيل
المثال لقاء
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في مصر متى كان الرد
للاحتلال بعد ذلك بدون الاستجابه لكل
المطالب المصريه بضروره التهدئه من قبل
الاحتلال الصهيوني ورفض فكانت مجزره نابلس
الذي استشهد فيها عشره فلسطينيين هل هذا
الكيان يمكن ان يعطى اي نوع من الثقه لكي
ينفذ هذه المطالب الذي تحدث عنها طيب هل
يمكن هل يمكن للسلطه هنا ان تذهب
هذا الهدف يعني هل هي ذاهبه من اجل ان
تلبي مطالب اسرائيل
بوقف المقاومه هل يمكن ان يحصل ذلك
يا سيدي هي تمارس هذا الدور بشكل واضح
وليس لديها اي مشكله في ذلك قال اسماعيل
جبر اللواء اسماعيل جبر بان الاداره
السلطه الفلسطينيه لا تخجل من تعاونها مع
الاحتلال هذه مساله لا بد ان تكون واضحه
الممارسات على الارض تؤكد بان احتلاء قوات
الاحتلال دخلت نابلس دخلت بناء على
تعليمات وصلتها من الاجهزه الامنيه في
السلطه الفلسطينيه لم تدخلها من تلقائي
انفسها وهذا يدلل على ان هناك تعاون امني
ولكن الاحتلال يريد تعاون اكبر دون ان
يقدم اي شيء للجانب الفلسطيني سيد محمد
هواش هل اسرائيل بحاجه لاختبار نوايا يعني
بعد كل هذه السنوات وكل ما تقوم به
اسرائيل في الاراضي الفلسفيه تحتاج الى
اختبار نوايا وفعلا منذ متى تقدم اسرائيل
امورا بالمجان للفلسطينيين
نعم هذه نقطه مهمه جدا اذا كنا نتحدث عن
عن يعني
مجتمع دولي نتحدث عن علاقات سياسيه نتحدث
عن موضوع سياسي بدرجه الاولى وليس يعني
موضوع مناكفات نعم نحن في في وضع دوله خطر
جدا كانت هناك محاولات لشطب القضيه
الفلسطينيه هناك حصار للشعب الفلسطيني
ايضا يعني حتى الدول العربيه في في وضع
صعب جدا لا تستطيع مساعده الشعب الفلسطيني
بما يجب يعني في الحدود التي يطلبها يعني
ويحتاجها الشعب الفلسطيني وهناك ضغوط
عربيه ودوليه على الفلسطينيين من اجل
تهدئه الاوضاع وحتى الان السلطه
الفلسطينيه ترفض يعني اعطاء اسرائيل اي
شيء مجاني على الاطلاق وبالتالي يعني كل
ما يتحدث به ضيفك الكريم
الزميل مصطفى لا صله له بالواقع على
الاطلاق هي تهيؤات
تاليفات وتوليفات لا علاقه لها بالواقع
على الاطلاق السلطه الفلسطينيه يعني كما
يقول يعني اذا كانت هي تستطيع يعني منع
المقاومه وهي لا تقوم بذلك اسرائيل تطالب
السلطه الفلسطينيه بالقيام بواجباتها في
المدن الفلسطينيه والسلطه الفلسطينيه
تعتبر ان هذه من واجباتها توفير شرعيه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه اينما كان
والطلب من اسرائيل وقف انتهاكاتها اليوميه
للمدن الفلسطينيه وليس يعني الحديث هو
الثرثره
والكلام الذي
لا يجلب للفلسطيني في الاطلاق نحن نريد
اتضحت الفكره
النقطه اخيره نقطه اخيره نقطه اخيره
بثواني فيما يتعلق باختبار الثقه هو ليس
للاسرائيليين نحن لا نثق بالاسرائيليين
على الاطلاق
ويعني الفصائل بيانات الفصائل تؤكد ذلك
وبيانات يعني التي تصدر عن فلسطين تؤكد
ذلك نحن نريد ان نقول لمصر وللاردن
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي تضغط
على الفلسطينيين بان انظروا اسرائيل هي
التي لا تريد تهدئه هي التي
يعني كانك تقول السلطه تريد ان تلقي الحجه
السلطه تريد ان تلقي الحجه سيد الصواف اذا
هناك ضغوط على السلطه هناك علاقات
اقليميه ودوليه لا تريد ان تقطعها السلطه
وبالتالي هي ذاهبه الى الاجتماع تحت هذه
الضغوط ولكن ليس بالضروره انها ستستجيب
للمطالب الاسرائيليه ستلقي الحجه لا اكثر
ولا اقل ما ردك
يا سيد يا سيدي اعتقد ان تجارب الواقع
تقول بان السلطه دائما تستجيب لكل ما
تريده سلطات الاحتلال وتدير الداره
الامريكيه ماذا قدمت الاداره الامريكيه
للسلطه الفلسطينيه حتى في ظل حكومه بايدن
اليست منظمه التحرير لا زالت مدرجه ضمن
قائمه الارهاب هذه مساله واضحه الم لماذا
الم تمارس حتى هذه اللحظه السلطات
الامريكيه ضغطا الاحتلال لوقف الاستيطان
بالامس كان هناك
اقرار بتسعه مستوطنات لبناء اليوم كان
هناك حديث عن بناء 3000 وعدد من المساكن
الى المستوطنين وهكذا اذا ماذا يمكن ان
تقدم هذه
الولايات المتحده والمجتمع الدولي للشعب
الفلسطيني ربما السلطه هي المستفيده
ونعتقد ان السلطه الان باتت في موقف حرج
جدا مش من الدول الغربيه او الدول العربيه
لا من ابناء شعبها الفلسطيني ولا قلت قبل
قليل لو كان هناك عاقلا في هذه السلطه
ربما استفاد مما حدث اول امس من دعاء عرين
الاسود للمواطنين في كل ضفه الغربيه وكانت
الاجابه شكرا
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من غزه وشكرا
لمحمد هواش الكاتب والمحلل السياسي كان
معنا من رام الله
[موسيقى]
اصدر قاده تحقيق المختص في قضايا مكافحه
الارهاب في تونس قرارات بسجن عدد من
القياديين الحزبيين والنشطاء السياسيين
بتهمه ما تصفه السلطات بالتامر على امن
الدوله من جانبه وصل الاتحاد التونسي
للشغل تنظيم وقفات احتجاجيه في ولايه عده
للتنديد بما يصفه باستهداف السلطات للعمل
النقابي
بوتيره متسارعه يتطور ملف حمله الاعتقالات
السياسيه في تونس فيما تسميها السلطه قضيه
التامر على امن الدوله الاحاله على القضاء
واوامر الايداع بالسجن ضد الموقوفين
اجراءات تمت دون مبرر قانوني ولا واقعي
بحسب هيئه الدفاع التي قاطعت الترافع
احتجاجا على ذلك تبين لنا ان الجانب
السياسي هو الجانب المحفز وهو الدافع
لاثاره هذا الملف في حد ذاته وثم في
التسييره تم تكوين وانشاء قرائن الادانه
بطريقه تعسفيه من قبل الاجهزه الامنيه
في المقابل اقتصرت وجهه النظر الرسميه حول
ما يحصل فيما جاء على لسان الرئيس قيس
سعيد حين وصف الموقوفين بالمجرمين
والارهابيين والمتامرين على امن الدوله
معتبرا محاسبت هؤلاء واجبا وطنيا
يتوتر المشهد السياسي في تونس على اكثر من
صعيد جدل الايقافات وما تثيره من تمديد
داخلي ودولي يتزامن مع تازم اجتماعي يواصل
من خلاله اتحاد الشغل تصعيده عبر التحركات
الاحتجاجيه
سلسله تحركات عماليه اسبوعيه يقودها اتحاد
الشغل لتشمل جميع الولايات في حركه
احتجاجيه تصعيديه ضد ما يصفه باستهداف
السلطه للعمل النقابي بعد اعتقاد احد
النقابيين والملاحقه القضائيه لاخرين يرى
الاتحاد ان استهدافه ياتي على خلفيه موقفه
الذي وصف فيه نهج الرئيس بالاستبداد
والتفرد في الحكم
لا للاستبداد والتفرج في الحكم
لاقصاء من السماء التونسي والمواطنين لا
لتحويل التونسي
هاجمونا
يزداد الوضع تعقيدا في تونس اذا امام حاله
الاضطراب الاجتماعي والسياسي وتقلص فرص
الذهاب نحو حوار سياسي جامع بعد موقف
الرئيس الاخير الذي انتقد فيه مبادره
اتحاد الشغل للانقاذ في الاثناء يمضي قيس
سعيد في نهجه الذي يصفه بمعركه التحرير
الوطني وتتمسك المعارضه برفضه واعتباره
خروجا عن الشرعيه والمسار الديمقراطي
ميساء الفطناسي الجزيره تونس
حملت حركه النهضه الرئيس قيس سعيد وقاضي
التحقيق المكلف بقضيه نور الدين البحيري
القيادي في الحركه مسؤوليه سلامته الجسديه
بعد نقله الى قسم الحالات المستعجله باحد
مستشفيات العاصمه واوضحت ان الحاله الصحيه
للبحير تدهورت نتيجه هبوط حاد في الدوره
الدمويه واوجاع حدث الصدر بسبب الاضراب عن
الطعام الذي يخوضه احتجاجا على محاولات
التصفيه التي يتعرض لها وطلبت حركه النهضه
بالافراج عن نور الدين البحيري فورا والكف
عن التنكيل والتشفي برموز المعارضه حسب
تعبيرها
الدكتور المنصف المرزوقي الرئيس التونسي
الصادق الدكتور منصف مرحبا بك
اذا كان هؤلاء
المعتقلون
يوحالون جميعا الى القضاء فان المشكله في
محاوله نظر القضاء في التهم
الموجهه اليهم واذا ثبتت براءتهم
يخرجون تماما كما يقول المؤيدون للرئيس
قيس سعيد
طيب اولا انا اريد ان اؤكد على تضامني
الكامل والشامل مع الاخوه والاخوات
المعتقلين والمعتقلات قضيه استقلاله
القضاء انا اريد ان اذكر ان حكم علي باربع
سنوات سجن هرب اترقى حتى يعني دعوه للمثول
امام المحكمه ولا المحامي وقضيه واضحه ان
هي تصفيات سياسيه انما اذا تسمح اريد ما
اركز عليه هو يعني الحزن والالم لانني ارى
يعني هذا الرجل يرتكب نفس الاخطاء التي
يرتكبها كل الديكتاتوريه وانا اريد ان
اذكر الرئيس السادات يعني لما ضاقت عليه
السبون وضعت كل كل خصومه في السجن في ليله
الليله جمع المئات بن عليه ايضا نفس الشيء
يعني لما ضاقت عليه السبل واجه الاسلاميين
بحركه اعتقالات كذا كذا وفي اخر مصاد نحن
نعلم ان ما الذي قضى على السادات ليس
المعارضون الذين وضعهم في السجن كما نعلم
ان الذي قضى على ابن علي ليس الاسلاميون
الذين وضعهم في السجن وانما كانت هناك قوى
خارجيه اخرى لم يتوقف لم يهتم بها
الديكتاتور لهذا ولدك نفس الشيء انا اشاهد
للاسف الشديد تكرر نفس الماساه ونفس
المهزله انه هذا الديكتاتور يخطئ كما يخطئ
كل الديكتاتوريا هو يضع الناس الذين هم
اغلبيتهم يعني مستعدين للحوار مستعدين
للتفاهم معهم
يضع هؤلاء الناس في السجن بينما القوى
الحقيقيه التي سترحل به يا اما يعني
المقربون منه او الشارع وبالتالي نحن
نشاهد عمليه عبثيه وهذه العمليه لعب فيها
تكلف الاما باهظه يعني للمناضلين وايضا
تكلف الام الباهظه للتونسيين وتضيع وقت
وتضيع جهد في عمليه محسومه مسبقا يعني هذا
الرجل لم يخرج من اللازم ولكن الدكتور
يعني الرئيس يتحدث بمنطق لا يتحدث بمنطق
المعارضه والموالاه هو يتحدث بمنطق التامر
على امن الدوله
ومجرمين وخونه وبالتالي هو اوكل الامر
للقضاء
انا بقول لك اذا كان في شخص تامر على امن
الدوله فهو هذا الرجل الذي انتخبناه كنا
على اساس انه سيحفظ الدستور فنقض الدستور
وحل يعني كحل كل المؤسسات الدستوريه
الموجوده التي تضم الاستقلال القضاء التي
تضم الاستقلال الصحافه التي محارب الفساد
كل هذه المشاكل كلها ثم استولى على كل
الصلاحيات ثم ورط بلادنا يعني في عمليات
مشيره مثل الازمه التي عملهانا مع افريقيا
حيث اذا كان فيه رجل يمكن ان اتهم بانه
خان الامانه ويشكل خطر على امن الدوله فهو
هذا الرجل وهو يدافع عن نفسه لانه يعرف
انه متهم بهذه التهم وبالتالي يوقيها على
الاخرين شوف سيدي الكريم لو كانت هناك
قضاء مستقل حقيقه
لما راينا هذه الفضائح التي رايناها يعني
في عاده هذا الرجل الذي هو السبب في
القانون لم يعرف في تاريخنا يعني تعامل
يعني مع القانون بالكيفيه المشينه التي
نراها اليوم يعني حتى بن علي انا اعرف
جيدا تلك الفتره او حتى بوركيبه يعني كان
هناك
الادنى من الاخراج المسرحي هذا الرجل تحت
هذا النظام لم يعد هناك اي اي ضوابط
دكتور المرزوقي على ما يستند الرئيس قيس
سعيد اذا كان يتعامل بهذه الطريقه وقد فاق
كما تقول من سبقه من الرؤساء على ماذا
يستند ويعتمد في الداخل
يعتمد بالاساس على السرديه التي استطاعت
القوه الثوره المضاده ان تسوقها وان هناك
عشريه سوداء وانه كذا وكذا يعتمد على هذا
وعلى الاخطاء التي ارتكبتها العديد من
الاطراف اليوم وهي ويتحمل مسؤوليتها انا
الان لا الوم كل هؤلاء الناس لانني متضامن
معهم واريد ان يتحدوا لكي نواجه هذه
الديكتاتوريه لكن فعلا هناك اخطاء عديده
ارتكبت من طرف الاطراف الموجوده الان التي
مهدت الطريق لهذا الشخص ثم هو يعني يلعب
الان على الغرائز الشعبويه انه كل
السياسيين فاسدين وانه كذا ويلعب حتى على
العنصريه عند الموجوده عند الناس ان هؤلاء
الافارقه ياكلون خبزكم الى اخره حيث هو
يغذي ويتغذى من احقر ما هو موجود يعني في
المجتمع التونسي والغرائزي لكن سؤالي ما
هي القوه التي يعتمد عليها في الداخل هل
تقصد انه يعتمد على شعبيه ما زالت اوازنه
في الداخل التونسي
كانت شعبيه لكن تتقلص يوما بعد يوم وهو
الان اعتبر انا ويا مازن يحتمي بجزء اجزاء
من الدوله العميقه التي يعني ترى فيها انه
ممكن ان يخلص تحتمي به او يخلص لكن
المشكله انا اقول لهذه القوه التي تحتمي
بهذا الرجل انتبهوا هذا الرجل محكوم عليهم
بالرحيل لانه الازمه الاقتصاديه والشرع
وربما هو الذي سيرحله وبالتالي انتم يعني
تراهنون على الحصان الخاسر هذا الرجل ارجع
تونس 30 سنه الى الوراء هو يتحدث عن عدم
الرجوع الى الوراء ارجعنا الى الخمسينات
والى الستينات والى السبعينات بينما تونس
كانت متقدمه جدا هو ارجحها الى الوراء
وبالتالي ان اعتبره حادث تاريخي وهذا
التاريخي الحادثه التاريخي سننتهي منه ولا
المشكله الان انه وضع في السجن الاطراف
الوحيده التي كانت بامكانها ان تتحاور معه
وان تجد حلول سلميه بالتالي هو لن يجد
امامه الا الشارع والشارع انا اعتبر انه
فعلا هذا الشارع الذي يعني مخلوق بالازمه
الاقتصاديه سيفهم العلاقه بينه وبين ازمته
يفعل كل ما يجب لكي تعود الثوره من جديد
الدكتور المنصف المرزوقي الرئيس تونس
السابق من باريس شكرا جزيلا لك
من مدينه سوسه في شرق تونس معنا قيصر
الصياح المحامي والباحث القانوني مرحبا بك
سيد قيصر ما الذي يستفيدوها الرئيس قيس
سعيد من وضع كل هؤلاء المعارضين الذين هم
مستعدون للحوار معه ان يضعهم في السجون
تحت عنوان الارهاب او الاجرام او التامر
على امن الدوله
شكرا مساء الخير اولا رئيس الجمهوريه
والقائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه ورئيس
المجلس الامن القومي التونسي وله كافه
الصلاحيات ليطلع على كل الملفات باعتباره
حامي ضمانه وسلامه امن تونس ثانيا رئيس
الجمهوريه لا يعادل الخصوم باعتبار الرئيس
جمهوريه لو كان يعادي الخصوم لقامت فتره
سابق سنتين
عديد الرموز هناك اربعين حزب في تونس الان
اربعه وخمسه عذاب تقريبا من شملتهم
الاعتقالات لم يقوم بها الرئيس قامت
بالنيابه العموميه التي يقفل لها القانون
ذلك في كل المواثيق والصكوك الدوليه
ويقفلوا لها القانون كذلك والدستور
بالماده 117
الحق في ان تقوم بصفه المستقل بتتبع ذوي
الشبهه ممن توفرت لديها معطيات بشانهم هذه
دوله القانون سياده الدول تقاس واما
بتطبيق القانون على الواقع او ترك القانون
والحابل على النابل لكن لم يتم لم يتم
اتباع الاجراءات القانونيه حسب الاصول في
في اعتقاله هؤلاء المعارضين
من قال انه لم يتبع الاجراءات القانونيه
وفي قضيه شيماء عيسى وفي قضيه جوهر بن
مبارك لم يتم اتباع الاجراءات القانونيه
المعمول بها في القانون التونسي
لسان الدفاع من من يمثلون الاشخاص
الموقوفين ونحن بالمناسبه نتاسف جدا لهذه
اللقافات هذه اللقافات بطبيعه الحال في كل
الحالات تخضع لسلطان النيابه العموميه
والقانون لكن كل متهم يعتبر دليل ان تثبتو
حتى بالمواثيق الدوليه والميثاق العالمي
لحقوق الانسان والماده 11 منه تحديدا
الماده 33 من الدستور التونسي الجديد يعني
كل ضمانات تقريبا مقفوله اما ان تكون هناك
بعض الاخلالات او الهنات على مستوى التتبع
او الاجراءات فهذا بطبيعه الحال من حق كل
شخص تضرر من حقوقه وكنت اتابع منذ قليل مع
الدكتور المصطف المنصوقي السؤال المتعلق
بحقوق الاشخاص في المطالبه برد الاعتبار
في صوره ما اذا ثبتت براءتهم الماده تسعه
من العهد الدولي للحقوق السياسيه المدنيه
تعطي لكل شخص تضرر اثناء تتبعه او اعتقاله
تعصبيا بالحق في كل سيد قيصر اذا كان كل
متهم بريء
واذا كان هؤلاء المتهمون
او بيد القضاء كيف يعطي الرئيس قيس سعيد
لنفسه الحق في ان يتهم ويطلق الاوصاف
عليهم بانهم مجرمون وبانهم متامرون وبانهم
ارهابيون في حين ان القضاء بين هلالين لم
يعطي كلمته بعد على اي اساس يطلق هذه
الصفات
من منظور الحقوقي صرف في كافه انحاء
العالم عندما احلل هذه الظاهره من الزاويه
الموضوعيه ولا نتركولوجيا السياسيه ادركوا
جيدا ان الخطاب السياسي ليس الخطاب
القانوني الخطاب السياسي يتعلق بوجهه نظر
الرئيس يتحدث عن مجرمين وارهابيين باعتبار
ان له 86 ملف امامه وتتعلق بشخصيات سياسيه
واريد ان اعرج هنا على نقطه هامه ومفصليه
في تاريخ تونس الان انا انزل القضاء
واعتبر ان القضاء مو حايدا الى ان يثبت ما
يخالف ذلك باعتبار ان الرئيس الاول لاعلى
محكمه في تونس وهو قاضي وليس له سياسه وله
ولا هو خاص من الرئيس احاله القضاء نفسه
واكبر وكيل نيابه عامه في تونس احالها
القضاء نفسه والان نتحدث اليوم تقريبا عن
عشرين معتقل من بين ليبي وجهت وهو موجود
بالخارج اجنبي وشخص اخر ايضا اجنبي وبعض
الشخصيات من رجال الاعمال اثره عمليات
تنصت واثره عمليات تدقيق شامله
الاعمال منذ تقريبا سته او سبعه اشهر شكرا
لك من مدينه سوسه في شرق تونس قيصر الصياح
المحامي والباحث القانوني
[موسيقى]
فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي حزمه عاشره من
العقوبات على روسيا بسبب حربها على
اوكرانيا تضاف الى عقوبات فرضتها مجموعه
الدول السبع وتستهدف العقوبات الجديده
بشكل محدد الصناعات العسكريه الروسيه
وايران التي يتهمها الغرب بدعم روسيا
عسكريا
عقوبه شديده تفرضها الولايات المتحده
ومجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي على
روسيا تستهدف ركنين اساسيين في اي مجهود
عسكري الترسانه والحلفاء الموثوقين تستهدف
العقوبات في الحزمه الجديده موسكو لكنها
تضمن طهران وتلوح بالعصا باقيا دون ان
تسميها
ولهذا تحاول في هذه الحزمه بحسب ما عرف
منها الحد من قدره روسيا على تجديد وتقويه
واستدامه ترسنتها العسكريه في الحرب ضد
اوكرانيا بالاستعانه بحلفاء واضحين مثل
ايران ومحتملين مثل الصين
حكم الغرب سبق وان صدر بحق ايران في حزم
سابقه مسيرات تشاهد كانت منطلقا لتضمين
كيانات وافراد ايرانيين بتهبه تقديم الدعم
العسكري لروسيا اما بالجين التي ترفض حتى
الان الاستفاف مع وجهه نظر الغرب في الحرب
على اوكرانيا فتخشى واشنطن انها تكاد
تقترب اكثر من الانحراف باتجاه الموقف
الروسي
فالولايات المتحده بدات تتحدث عن ان الصين
تدرس جديا دعم روسيا عسكريا ولكل ما سبق
شملت الحزمه العشيره قيودا اكثر صرامه في
مجال تصدير التكنولوجيا وصلع مزدوجه
الاستخدام
فاضافت قرابه 96 كيان الروسيا تتهمه
اوروبا بتقديم دعم المباشر للمجمع العسكري
والصناعي الروسي
ووسعت الحزمه الجديده من التدابير
التقليديه ضد كيانات وافراد ايرانيين
لتشمل سبع شركات قد يكون من بينها القدس
وشهد لصناعه الطيران بتهمه تزويد روسيا
بسلع ذات استخدام مزدوج خاصه الطائرات
المسيره بحسب ما اعلنت جوزيف بوريل مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
اكثر من عشره الاف اجراء تقليدي فرض على
روسيا منذ بدء الحرب بحسب ما تقول موسكو
اجراءات لا يزال الجدل يدور حول نجاعتها
بعد عام على الحرب
وتعليقا على العقوبات الغربيه الجديده قال
سفير الروسي في واشنطن اناطولي ان تنوض ان
تعليق عضويه روسيا في مجموعه العمل المالي
خطوه خطيره لانها ستلحق ضررا كبيرا
بالجهود العالميه لمكافحه غسيل الاموال
واضاف ان الولايات المتحده وحلفائها فشل
في محاولاتهم لحنق روسيا بالعقوبات لانها
تعودت العيش تحت ضغط سياسي واقتصادي ووصف
السفير الروسي العقوبات التي فرضتها
الولايات المتحده ومجموعه السبع امس على
بلاده بانها طائشه ولن تؤدي الى تخلي
موسكو عن سياستها المستقله
تظاهر الالاف في العاصمه الالمانيه برلين
للمطالبه بوقت ارسال الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا
وباحياء المفاوضات مع روسيا ورفع
المتظاهرون الذين خرجوا بالتزامن مع مرور
عام على حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا شعار
انهضوا من اجل السلام وبحسب شرطه
الالمانيه فقد شارك في المظاهره نحو عشره
الاف شخص
وتولت ردود الفعل على المبادره الصينيه
لانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا وقال الرئيس
الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون انخراط الصين في
جهود السلام امر جيد وكشف عن زياره سيقوم
بها في ابريل المقبل اما الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن فقال انه لم يرى جديدا في هذه
المبادره وان المستفيد الوحيد من الحرب هو
روسيا
[موسيقى]
اختارت بيجين ان توافق مبادرتها لانهاء
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا ذكرى مرور سنه
على هذه الحرب
تقدم الصين نفسها طرفا محايدا يمكنه ان
يلعب دور الوسيط وتبني مبادرتها على اربعه
اسس احترام سياده الدول والابتعاد عن
عقليه الحرب البارده وانهاء القتال
واستئناف والحوار في الغرب استقبلت مبادره
الصين ببرود وبدا ان الرئيس الفرنسي هو
الاستثناء
في المقابل قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
انه لم يرى جديدا في هذه المبادره وانه
ليس هناك ما يؤشر الى وجود مستفيد من هذه
الحرب سوى روسيا واوضح ان فكره ان الصين
ستتفاوض على نتيجه حرب غير عادله تماما
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا هي فكره غير عقلانيه
وفق تعبيره موقف بايدن من المبادره
الصينيه كان متوقعا فادارته تقول ان الصين
تدرس مد روسيا بالسلاح لدعم حربها في
اوكرانيا الطرفان المعنيان مباشره
بالمبادره الصينيه استقبلاها بصيغه هذا
جيد ولكن
لا اعتقد انه مخطط سلام صيني لا يتعلق
الامر بتوصيه او اعلان لا يشكل ما اعلنته
الصين شيئا يمكن البناء عليه اعتقد ان
الصين كشفت عن افكارها الصين بدات تتحدث
عن اوكرانيا وهذا جيد جدا
ان الاهم هي الافعال التي ستتبع اقوال
الصين واك ازمه لقاء ناظره الصيني اما
موسكو فقد قالت انها تثمن عاليا الرغبه
الصادقه للاصدقاء في الصين لانهاء الصراع
في اوكرانيا لكن اي حل يجب ان يعترف
بالاوضاع الجديده على الارض تشير خارجيه
الروسيه هنا لضم موسكو اربعه اقاليم
اوكرانيه وهذا ما يتناقض مع احد اسس
المبادره الصينيه وهو سياده الدول في
اجتماعات وزراء ماليه دول العشرين انضمت
الصين الى جانب روسيا دون باقي الاعضاء في
رفض الفقرتين المتعلقتين بالحرب في
اوكرانيا رغم انهما لا تحملان اي اتهام
مباشر لموسكو ويدفع هذا الدعم الدبلوماسي
الصيني لروسيا في الامم المتحده وخارجها
الدول الغربيه الى النظر لبيجين كحليف
لموسكو في حربها ولذلك يشككون في مبادرتها
للسلام
معنى من بيجين فيكتور نائب رئيس مركز
الصين والعولمه ومن فيرجينيا الادميرال
ويليام فالون القائد السابق للقياده
الوسطى الامريكيه ورئيس قسم الصين في
المعاهد الدوليه للدراسه الدبلوماسيه
بجامعه جورج تاون نبدا معك سيد ويليام ما
الذي يجعل الولايات المتحده الان بعد سنه
على هذه الحرب ان تشكك وترجح ان الصين
متجهه نحو دعم روسيا عسكريا في هذه الحرب
ما هي المؤشرات لديها
انا ليس لدي اي اطلاع او تفاصيل حول هذا
الامر قرات التقارير الصحفيه كما فعلتم
انتم وليس لدي اي تفاصيل حول اي معلومات
استخباريه قد تتوفر لدى الحكومه ولكن
بالتحليل هل من مصلحه الصين الان وهي التي
تقدم مبادره من اجل ان تكون وسيطا في هذه
الحرب هل من مصلحه يا ان تنحاز بهذا الشكل
وتدعم عسكريا بعد مرور سنه على الحرب تدعم
روسيا عسكريا
بالتاكيد حسب رايي ليس من المنطقي ابدا
ذلك لا اعرفه ابي اي شيء عن هذا ولكن
شاهدنا امور اغرب من ذلك مثلا مؤخرا
من طاعه المراقبه الذي طار فوق الولايات
المتحده وفي نفس الوقت كان لدينا لاول مره
حوار مع الصين وبالتالي هذا ايضا كان امر
غير منطقيا بالنسبه لي لكن يستطيع القول
ان فكره
وصوله للتسويه متفاوضيه لهذه الحرب
الكريهه ولا في فكره جيده ليس فقط مستحقه
من الزمن بعيد ولكن ايضا لابد ان تحصل ان
اجلا وبالتالي لكن لابد ان نعرف السبب هذه
المشكله وهو
السلوك العدواني الذي قام به بفوت وبدئه
بهذا الحفظ ضد دوله مجاوره اذا الصوره
الكبرى في رايي ينبغي ان تنتهي واننا يمكن
ان نرحب اي اي مقاربه معقوله ومنطقيه
للاتصال بالطرفين للجلوس
ومناقشه هذا الامر واعتقد ان ذلك في مصلحه
الجميع في كل القطاعات سيد فيكتور جاو
كيف يمكن للصين ان تقدم مبادره
لانهاء الحرب لكن في مجموعه العشرين نراها
منحزه كليا
لروسيا كيف يمكن ان تكون وسيطا وهي في
الاجتماعات الدوليه تنحاز لروسيا بشكل
واضح
شكرا جزيلا على هذه الاستضافه اولا نحن
نتحدث عن حرب انطلقت منذ عاما والاوان قد
ان للتوصلي الى اطار دبلوماسي كي نتحدث عن
وضع حدا لهذه الحرب بشكل يؤدي الى السلام
السلام لن يكون سهلا ولن يكون مباشرا
والمفاوضات سوف تكون في غايه الصعوبه ولكن
بغض النظر عن ثمن السلام سوف يكون افضل من
الحرب لان الحرب في اوكرانيا تصبح وبسرعه
حربا بالوكاله بين الولايات المتحده من
جهه وروسيا من جهه اخرى وروسيا هي من بين
القوى النوويه الكبرى والحرب في اوكرانيا
تتضمنها مخاطر بان تتفلت الامور ويتوسع
النزاع وقد نصل الى حرب باسلحه غير
تقليديه لذلك تدعو الصين بشكل ثابت لاحلال
السلام عوضا عن تصعيد الحرب سواء لعبت
الصين الدوره الوساطه او اي دوله اخرى اذا
ما لعبت الدوله الوساطه هذا مساله اخرى
هذه مساله اخرى ولكن يجب ان نركز على
المفاوضات عوضا عن اطاله امد الحرب ولكن
هل الصين سيد جاو عذرا عذرا لكن هل الصين
هل الصين متجهه الان
لدعم روسيا عسكريا هذا ما تتحدث به تقارير
استخباراتيه وهذا ما بدات تعلنه بشكل واضح
اوساط امريكيه
في البدايه هذه محضو تكهنات وهي مضلله ان
تقول الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انها
خلصت بان الصين تفكر بدعم روسيا على
المستوى العسكري اولا ما من حاجه كي تدعم
الصين روسي نحن نعرف ان لروسيا قدرات
شامله وكامله وواسعه لتصنيع كل انواع
الاسلحه بما في ذلك الاسلحه النوويه وهي
ليست بحاجه لطلب المساعده العسكريه من
الصين ثانيا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وحلف شمال الاطلسي هي الجهه التي
تمد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه وهذا يؤدي الى
اطاله امد الحرب ومقتل المدنيين في
اوكرانيا براينا من الضروري ان تتوقف هذه
الدول عن امداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
للافصاحي في المجال امام السلام الذي يمكن
ان يبدا
بوقف لاطلاق النار ليصل في النهايه الى
الحل بشان المساله المرتبطه باوكرانيا من
ويليام يعني كما كما استمعت روسيا ليست
بحاجه للمساعده يمكنها ان
تصنع ما تشاء من من الاسلحه والناتو هو
الذي يتحمل المسؤوليه باعتباره انه يضخ
بالاسلحه والمساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا
ان نقول باني اختلف جوهريا مع العديد ما
قاله السيد كارو اننا نتفق على شيء واحد
هو انه لابد ان تكون هناك تسويه تفاوضيه
لهذه الحرب كاولويه ولكن ما بعد ذلك انا
لا اتفق مع معظمها قال من اراء ابتداء
بمساله
ان الغاب يستخدم اوكرانيا بالحرب الوكاله
من غزا من بوتين هو الذي غزا اوكرانيا هم
يدافعون انفسهم الولايات المتحده دول
كثيره في العالم تحاول تعطيني مايكفي
ليقاوموا هذه ويواجه هذا هذا الغزو
لاراضيه من جهه خارجيه هناك مشاكل اخرى
كثيره ولا اعرف بالضبط ما الذي تحتاجه
روسيا وما الذي قد يطلبونه من الصين ولكن
بالتاكيد بحاجه لاشياء ما فلو نظرنا الى
ما كيف انهم توجهوا الى ايران وطلبوا منها
الكثير من العجلات والمسيرات والذخائر وما
الى ذلك ولكن في رايي ان الصين اذا كانت
جاده في عرض السلام
مفاوضات سلام فانني اعتقد انه سيكون مصلحه
الجميع ان تبقى لماذا
عفوا سيد ويليام سيد ويليام اذا كنت تتفق
على ان هذه الحرب يجب ان تنتهي لماذا سارع
الرئيس بايدن الى يعني بشكل
مغلف الى رفض المبادره الصينيه واعتبر انه
لم يرى فيها جديدا وانها سيئه ما دام
بوتين قد
رحب بها باختصار ارجوك
لا اعرف ما هو محتوى العرض الذي قدم لم
اشد ذلك مكتوبا ليس لدي فكره حول ما الذي
اقترح عليكم ولكن من وجهه نظري انا لو
كانت هذه فعلا
مبادره غير منحازه ومفتوحه ومنطقيه فانني
اعتقد ان الاطراف المعقوله ستاخذ بها
وتلقي نظره عليها فاذا لم تكن كذلك اذا
كانت مجرد كلام في كلام فانه ذلك
عذرا هنا سيد جو باختصار شديد عندما تتحدث
المبادره الصينيه عندما تتحدث عن
سياده الدول هل تعني ذلك
بعوده اوكرانيا الى حدودها السابقه
باختصار شديد ارجوك
بكل تاكيد ان هذا الموقف الثابت للصين على
مر العقود لوحده الاراضي وسياده الدول
الاعضاء في الامم المتحده يجب ان تحفظ
وميثاق الامم المتحده يجب ان يحترم خصوصا
في ازمنه الحروب ليس فقط في اوكرانيا بل
في كل انحاء العالم هذا هو موقف الصين
الثابت بالنسبه الى روسيا واوكرانيا يتعين
عليهما ان تعمل من اجل احلال السلام من
خلال الدبلوماسيه هذا سؤال ثاني او مساله
ثانيه شكرا جزيلا لك من بجين فيكتور جاي
جاو نائب رئيس مركز الصين
والعولمه وشكرا
للادميرال ويليام فالون كان معنا من
فيرجينيا
[موسيقى]
اعلن وزير العدل التركي باكير بوزداد
اعتقال 184 شخصا بتهمه الاهمال في ملفات
المباني التي انهارت بفعل الزلزال الجنوبي
البلاد وذكرت وكاله انباء الاناضول
التركيه ان من بين الموقوفين رئيس بلديه
نورداغ بولايه غاز عنتاب بعد خضوعه
لتحقيقات في ملابسات انهيار مباني جراء
الزلزال كما اشار الوزير التركي الى
اعتقاد 179 شخصا بتهمه القيام باعمال نهب
خلال فتره الزلزال
وقد ارتفعت حصيله القتلى في كل من تركيا
وسوريا الى اكثر من خمسين الفن بينما تم
تسجيل اكثر من تسعه الاف هزه ارتداديه حتى
الان وقالت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه ان تركيا سجلت 44 الفا
ومئتين وثمانيه عشره
حاله وفاه بينما ارتفعت حصيله وقتل
الزلزال في سوريا الى 5000 وتسعمائه
في سوريا تواصل فرق الدفاع المدني في عدد
من البلدات في غرب ادلب رفع الانقاض
والكتل الخرسانيه المتصدعه من الامنيه
التي تضررت جراء الزلزال الذي تعرضت له
المنطقه في السادس من الشهر الجاري وقالت
وحده تنسيق الدعم في مناطق المعارضه
السوريه ان 100 وسبعه وثلاثين بلده ومدينه
في شمال غرب سوريا تضررت نتيجه الزلزال
وان مئات الالاف من السكان سيبقون لفتره
طويله
دون ماوى
مديره العمليات الدوليه في الاتحاد الدولي
لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
مرحبا بك سيده كارولين اولا نود منك
تقييما
لعمليات الان عمليات الايواء التي هي
الابرز في هذه المرحله تقييم لعمليات
الايواء والاغاثه المستمره اكان في جنوب
تركيا او في سوريا
شكرا جزيلا لاستضافه معكم هذه الليله وان
يقدر ذلك الى حد كبير طبعا نحن لا نختارنا
الى ثلاثه اسابيع منذ بدء هذه الكارثه هو
لابد ان نواصل الجهود والتركيز على هذه
الكارثه لان الاحتياجات كبيره جدا ستبقى
كبيره في المستقبل ثم يتعلق بالماوى حاليا
هذه اولويه قصوى كما نشاهد من الصور التي
عرضت فان مستوى الدمار
وبناء
وتدمير المنازل وكل التحتيه والتاثير على
الناس لا ينبغي ان اقل من الشان حجم هذه
المهمه وبالتالي الماوى هو اهم اول الشتاء
شديد في سوريا وتركيا والناس يعيشون في
العراء ويتعرضون الطقس القاسي وبالتالي
لابد لا ننتقم اقل مسائل الحمايه حتى ان
كانت بسيطه فهي ضروريه جدا وهي مهمه
لهؤلاء الباقين الناجين طبعا ان العيش هنا
طبعا الخيم الان جيده وسريعه
وبحيث يستطيع ولكن طبعا الخيام ليست الحل
المدى البعيد الان نحن سننتقل الى المرحله
التاليه الناس يودون الشفاعه
والنقاهه باسرع وقت ممكن
الماساه يعيشونها بعضهم فقط عوائلهم او
جيرانهم او اصدقائهم والمجتمع كله متاثر
والان بدا ان بتقديم بعض الدعم الذي يبدو
كان الحياه الطبيعيه لكن ايضا لحمايه
الناس من الظروف القاسيه التي ما زالوا
يشكون منها واننا نعطيهم طفله احتياجات
التي انقاذ حياتهم وهذا امر ما زال ضروريا
وهل هذا ينطبق بنفس المستوى على جنوب
تركيا وشمال سوريا
نعم احتياجات كبيره في البلدين طبعا ان
مركز
الزتان حتى الثالثه لانها التي حصلت بدايه
الاسبوع هذا كل هذه مراكز
الزلزال كانت في تركيا عدد الناس
المتاثرين والذي حصر تحت الركامي وعدد
القتلى مع الاسف اكبر في تركيا ولكن
كمؤسسات مساعدات انسانيه من واجبنا ان
نعمل للتنسيق مع كل المؤسسات وكل السلطات
للتاكد نوفي كل احتياجات الموجوده الامر
لا يتعلق بانحياز الى هذا الجانب وذاك بل
الامر يتعلق بالنفهم ما هي الاحتياجات في
تركيا نفسها وكذلك في سوريا ونحاول معالجه
ذلك بافضل طريقه استجابه ممكنه
شكرا جزيلا لك كارولين هولت مديره
العمليات الدوليه في الاتحاد الدولي
لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر من
جنيف
مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا بعد فاصل قصير
نلقاكم على راس الساعه بحول الله
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه مرحبا بكم
من جديد واليكم تذكيرا بعناوين الحصاد
لهذه الليله
اجتماع بالعقبه اليوم الاحد يضم مسؤولين
سياسيين وامنيين فلسطينيين واسرائيليين
الى جانب الاردن ومصر والولايات المتحده
مسؤول فلسطيني يقول للجزيره ان اللقاء
يهدف لضمان وقف اجراءات اسرائيل الاحاديه
فصائل المقاومه في جنين تقول انه سيمنح
الاحتلال فرصا لارتكاب مزيد من الجرائم
والفصائل بغزه تحذر وتقول ان المشاركين
خارجون عن الاجماع الوطني
حمله الاعتقالات تتصاعد في تونس مثيره
مزيدا من الاسئله
حبس خمسه موقوفين من الشخصيات السياسيه
المعارضه على ذمه التحقيق فريق الدفاع
يقاطع جلسه المرافعه بسبب ما اعتبره غيابا
لشروط محاكمه عادله وقوى سياسيه تصف
الاعتقالات بمحاوله لتصفيه الخصوم
عاشر حزمه عقوبات اوروبيه على روسيا مع
دخول الحرب عامها الثاني الاتحاد الاوروبي
يصفها بالاوسع نطاقا ويحذر حلفاء موسكو
الصين تعرقل اقرار بيان ختامي الاجتماعي
وزراء ماليه العشرين حول اوكرانيا
ومظاهرات في برلين وباريس للاحتجاج على
تزويد كياف بالاسلحه وللمطالبه بارساء
السلام في اوكرانيا
اكثر من خمسين الف قتيل ضحايا زلزاليه
تركيا وسوريا وبعد تضرر اكثر من 160 الف
مبنى في مدن تركيا عده انقره توسع التحقيق
في الانهيارات اعتقال اكثر من 180 شخصا
وملاحقات قضائيه تشمل 600 شخص
وضعت الامكانات يقوض جهود الاغاثه في شمال
سوريا والمنظمات المحليه تحصي مئات الالاف
دون ماوى
[موسيقى]
يعقد اليوم الاحد في مدينه العقبه
الاردنيه مؤتمر امني يجمع وفدا من السلطه
الفلسطينيه واسرائيل بمشاركه مسؤولين
امنيين من الولايات المتحده والاردن ومصر
وقال مسؤول فلسطيني كبير للجزيره ان
الاجتماع يهدف لتحقيق تفاهمات حول فتره
انتقاليه تضمن وقت اسرائيل الاجراءات
الاحاديه من استيطان وهدم واقتحامات لمده
سته اشهر يتم خلالها التحضير لتهدئه
والانتقال الى مسار اكثر اتساعا واضاف
المسؤول الفلسطيني ان اسرائيل رفضت مشاركه
اطراف عربيه اخرى ادت استعدادها لذلك
واشار المسؤول الى ان الاردن ومصر
والولايات المتحده تبذل قصار جهدها لمنع
انفجار الاوضاع خلال شهر رمضان والاعياد
اليهوديه في مارس المقبل
من جانبها استنكرت فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في غزه مشاركه السلطه
الفلسطينيه في الاجتماع الامني المزمل
عقده في مدينه العقبه الاردنيه واعتبرت في
بيان ان مشاركه السلطه الفلسطينيه طعمه
جديده لتضحيات شعب الفلسطيني وخيانه
لتضحيات الشهداء وحذرت فصائل المقاومه من
خطوره اجتماع العقبه وقالت انه استكمال
لمخططات التامر على الشعب الفلسطيني
وقضيته ومحاوله جديده لاستئصال مشروع
المقاومه واضاف البيان ان المشاركين في
هذا الاجتماع خرجون عن الاجماع الوطني ولا
يمثلون الا انفسهم
وقلت الاذرع العسكريه التابعه لفصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في مخيم جنين ان
اجتماع العقد الامني لا يصب في مصلحه
الشعر الفلسطيني بل يمثل خدمه مجانيه
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي
واستنكرت فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
مشاركه السلطه الفلسطينيه الاجتماع وقالت
ان هذه المشاركه تاتي في اتجاه معاكس
للاجماع الوطني الرافض لها
لا يصب في مصلحه شعبنا
بل يمثل خدمه مجانيه
للاحتلال الصهيوني المجرم الذي لا يتوقف
عن العدوان على شعبنا وارضنا ومقدساتنا
ان مشاركه السلطه الفلسطينيه في هذا
اللقاء تاتي في اتجاه المعاكس
للاجماع الوطني الرافض لهذا اللقاء
والمطالب بالغائه
فالغاء هذا اللقاء هو اضعف قرار يمكن ان
تتخذه السلطه
كرد على جرائم حكومه الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
معنا الدكتور ستيفن زونس استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه سان فرانسيسكو سيد زونس
اي دور سيكون للولايات المتحده في اجتماع
العقبه هو اجتماع اسرائيلي فلسطيني
بمشاركه دول اقليميه ولكن ذات طابع امني
بحت اي دوله ستلعبه الولايات المتحده فيها
كذا اجتماع
الولايات المتحده لعبت دورا لمحاوله
تقريبا الجانبين الى بعضهما هو هناك قلق
في واشنطن القتال بين
القوه الاحتلال الاسرائيليه والمجموعات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه قد استصاعد وازداد
ولكن المشكله هيك مثلك كل الاجتماعات
الاخرى التي نظمتها الولايات المتحده حول
الامن تفشل هذا الاجتماع في التاكيد على
المشكله الاساسيه وهي الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وبوجود هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي فيها متطرفون من اليمين
المتطرف الذين حتى لا يتظاهرون بتاييد
فكره وجود الدوله الفلسطينيه وايضا السلطه
الفلسطينيه
تستخدم مصداقيتها او تفقد مصداقيتها ما
بين الفلسطينيين فقط لانها تتصرف كانها
سجان في سجون في الخاص بها وبالتالي من
الصعب ان كيف يمكن الولايات المتحده
التقرب الجانبين فقط تغيير جوهري في
السياسه الامريكيه يمكن ان يحرك الامور
الى الامام ولا ارى ذلك قادما في المستقبل
القريب طيب
يعني هذا الامر يطرح تساؤلا هل تقزم دور
الولايات المتحده من البحث عن
يعني عن حل على اساس الدولتين كما تعلن
باكثر من مناسبه الى المشاركه في اجتماعات
تبحث ببنود امنيه داخل شوارع وازقه الضفه
الغربيه يعني الى هذا الحد تصل يصل دور
الولايات المتحده
ان الولايات المتحده وموقفها هو من حيث
الاساس كان ان الجانبين ينبغي ان يتفقا
على حل الخلافات بينهما ولكن ذلك يتجاهل
عدم التناسب في القوى ما بين
القوات الاحتلال او المحتلين الاسرائيلين
والفلسطينيين الذين هم معرضون متعرضون
للاحتلال هذا يشبه ما مساله ما قام به
العراق باحتلال الكويت في 1990 اذ فلو قال
ان لابد الكويت والعراق ان يحل المشكله ما
بينهما كلا لا يكون التعامل هكذا مع حالات
الاحتلال الاجنبي الطريقه الوحيده لتحقيق
تقدم هي لو ان الولايات المتحده
او غالبيه مجتمع ايضا جمعت معها كلهم
الدولي وادركت واكدت على ضروره انسحابه
اسرائيل لكن الولايات المتحده لم حتى تلمح
تلميحا بذلك بل تقدم الدعم للقوه المحتله
لماذا
فقط هنا يعني لماذا الولايات المتحده لا
تقوم بهذا الدور يعني هي عاجزه ام هي فعلا
غير جاده في حل جوهري والضغط على اسرائيل
باختصار ارجوك
الولايات المتحده والتقليديا تقدم الدعم
لحلفائها حتى لو قاموا بانتهاكات للقانون
الدولي والقيم الولايات المتحده ادعمت
اندونيسيا عندما احتلت تيمور ودعمت المغرب
احتلالها في الصحراء الغربيه اذا دعم
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للضفه الغربيه مع
الاسف لا يختلف عن ذلك الامر لا يتعلق فقط
باللوبي مؤيد لاسرائيل بل هذه
تتعلق الامر بالهيمنه والامبرياليه
الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط
شكرا
جزيلا لك كنت معنا من سان فرانسيسكو
الدكتور
[موسيقى]
شهد تونس تسارعا في وتيره التوقيفات
والاعتقالات حيث اكدت هيئه الدفاع عن
المعتقلين فيما تعرف بقضيه التامر على امن
الدوله اصدار قرار جديد بالسجن في حق
القياديين بجبه الخلاص الوطني المعرضه في
تونس رضا بلحاج وشيماء عيسى وغازي شواشي
وكان قد التحقيق في قضايا مكافحه الارهاب
قد اصدر في وقت سابق من فجر اليوم قرارات
بالسجن في حق كل من الناشطين السياسيين
ايام التركي وعبد الحميد الجلاصي ورجل
الاعمال كمال الطيب والقيادي بجبه الخلاص
جوهر بن مبارك والامين العام للحزب
الجمهوري عصام الشاب
ككره ثلج متدحرجه تتفاعل قضيه الاعتقالات
التي شهدتها تونس بعد اعتقال ثم سجن
شخصيات تشمل السياسيين ورجال اعمال ضمنما
تسميه السلطات التونسيه قضيه التامر على
امن الدوله بدات الاعتقادات السبت الحادي
عشر من فبراير الجاري بمداهمه قوه الامن
منزل الناشط السياسي والعضو السابق بحزب
التكتل خيام التركي واعتقاله دون توضيح
الاسباب في اليوم نفسه اوقف الناشط
السياسي والقيادي السابق بحركه النهضه عبد
الحميد الجلاصي وطال الاعتقال رجل الاعمال
التونسي المعروف كمال لطيف بتاريخ 14 من
فبراير اوقف الناشط السياسي الازهر
العكرمي لكنه احيل على قاضي تحقيق مختلف
وتواصلت سلسله الاعتقادات بايقاف عصام
الشابي الامين العام للحزب الجمهوري ثم
التحق بقائمه المعتقلين القياديه بجبهه
الخلاص شيماء عيسى والقيادي بالجبهه جوهر
بن مبارك يوما
وشملت احدث الاعتقالات رضا بالحاج
القياديه بجبهه الخلاص المعارضه والمحامي
غازي الشواشي الامين العام السابق للتيار
الديمقراطي وفق عناصر من هيئه الدفاع
تمحور التحقيق مع مختلف الشخصيات حول
اجتماعات شاركوا فيها ونظمها النشط
السياسي خيم التركي بشان الوضع العام في
البلاد كما تمحورت اسئله التحقيق حول
اجتماع عقده التركي مع دبلوماسيين
السابقين ولم يرد حديث حتى اللحظه عن
اسئله مرتبطه بالتامر او الانتماء لتنظيم
ارهابي او محاوله اغتيال رئيس الدوله وهو
ما تواتر في وقت سابق قرارات الايداع
بالسجن ليست قضائيه بل سياسيه بحته وفق
هيئه الدفاع وهو مدفعها الى مقاطعه
الترافع احتجاجا على ذلك والانتفاء ابسط
شروط المحاكمه العادله وللتذكير وخلال
زيارته لوزاره الداخليه اكد الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد ان توهم الموقوفين تتعلق
بالتامر على امن الدوله معتبرا محاسبتهم
واجبا وطنيا تلحق بهذه القضايا قضيه
المدير العام لاذاعه موزاييك نور الدين
بوطار الذي وضع السجن بتهم في قضايا فساد
وفق السلطات بينما قالت هيئه الدفاع انه
يدفع ضريبه برنامج سياسي انتقد كل الحكومه
وكل السلطات ومنذ نحو الشهرين يقبع علي
العريض نائب رئيس حركه النهضه ورئيس حكومه
سابق في السجن بتهمه ما يعرف بقضيه
التسفير الى بؤر التوتر بين مطار التحقيق
جوانب اخرى وفق هيئه الدفاع واعتقل
القيادي في حركه النهضه ووزير العدل
السابق نور الدين البحيري وودع السجن على
خلفيه دعوه اطلقها على مواقع التواصل
لمقاومه الانقلاب وفق محاميه دانت جبهه
الخراص المعرضه ما وصفته بالمعامله السيئه
والمهينه لمعتقلين السياسيين وقالت انها
لن تنال من قناعتهم ولن تزيدهم الا تصميما
على مقاومه الاستبداد والدوده عن الحقوق
والحريات
ونظم الحزب الجمهوري وقفه تضامنيه مع
امينه العام عصام الشابي وبقيه المعتقلين
رفعت فيها شعارات تندد بما يصفه بالانقلاب
ودوله البوليس ودانت حركه النهضه بشده ما
اعتبرتها توسعا لحمله الاعتقالات
العشوائيه ضد رموز المعارضه ودعت للكف عن
محاوله تحويل البلاد الى حاله امنيه
تمهيدا لعوده الديكتاتوريه
وتعليقا على الوضع العام في البلاد قال
المتحدث الرسمي باسم اتحاد الشغل سامي
الطاهري ان تونس في خطر وان منظمته لن
تقبل بالاستبداد وستحاربه وتحاسبه
معنى من واشنطن جوردن السفير الامريكي
السابق في تونس
الولاده المتحده كيف يمكن ان تنظر الى هذا
الواقع تحديدا الى حمله الاعتقالات التي
تتسع
لمعارضي الرئيس قيس سعيد في تونس
اعتقد ان
كنا في تونس عندما بدا الربيع العربي هناك
عندما قام الشعب التونسي ببطوله بالاطاحه
ب 23 سنه من حكم الاستبداد بن علي ومن اسف
ان نرى الان هذا الهجوم
والاعتقالات التي يقوم بها الرئيس عيد
وهذا طبعا يشمل اكثر من عشره من قاده
المعارضه جرى اعتقالهم ورئيس اكثر
محطه راديو راديو موزاييك ايضا اعتقل بسبب
لان راضيه موزاييك انتقد الرئيس هذا هذه
محاوله
لقضاء على اي احتجاج وهذا يعود بنا الى
ايام بن علي
ولكن سالتك هنا برايك كيف يمكن ان تتعاطى
الولايات المتحده مع امر من من هذا النوع
داخل تونس
اعتقد انه فيما يتعلق
بمهر وان نفوذ او الضغط الذي تمتلكه ولايه
المتحده فما على نفوذها محدود جدا فيبدو
ان الرئيس السعيد لا يقبل او لا يسمعه ما
يسمع اي ارشاداتنا ونصائح من اصدقائه وان
السفيره الجديد وصل مؤخرا الى تونس الرئيس
السفير الاهود ذكر بان مساعدات الامنيه
الامريكيه لتونس قللت وخفضت وهذا طبعا امر
مؤسف بالنسبه لامن تونس
وان احد
وسائل الضغطه تزالت ممكنه للولايه المتحده
هي
النفوذها في صندوق النقد الدولي لتفكر
بتقديم واحد فاصل تسعه مليون دولار مليار
دولار
لمساعدات لتونس يمكن الولايات المتحده ان
تمارس نفوذها في صندوق النقد الدولي ولكن
ام لا لابد ان ننتظر لنرى هل تشبه هذه
المرحله
بمرحله الرئيس السابق زين العابدين بن علي
انا
كنت
سفيره في تونس سفير الولايات 2009 الى
2012 وبالتالي شاهدته ايام بن علي
وكما قال احد كتاب الامريكان
التاريخ لا يكرر نفسه ولكن غالبا ما
يتناغم وهذا بالتاكيد صحيح فالهجوم
الذي يحصل الان على على المعارضين تحت
قياده رئيس سعيد هو يذكرنا بالهجوم الذي
حصل على المعارضين اثناء ابن علي لا
تسيئوا فهمي كان الوضع اثناء بن علي اسوا
بكثير لكن مع ساف الاتجاه التي يصير عليه
من سعيد ليس لا يعد بالكثير
لا يعدو بالكثير ولكن هل يعني بحسب
مقارنتك هل يمكن ان تكون النتيجه مشابهه
اعتقد ان النتيجه يمكن تكون متشابهه جدا
فقد شهدنا فعلا لحد الان تحت اداره الرئيس
سعيد بانه قد انتقل عبره السنه والنصف
الماضي اكثر من سنه ونصف قد انتقل الى
تجريد البرلمان من طول صلاحياته
واسس حزبا عفوا البرلمانة جديدة هو اضعف
ما كان عليه الفنان في فتره ما بعد الثوره
هذا احد الامثله فقط والمثال الاخر وكما
قلت هو الهجوم واعتقال المعارضين شكرا
جزيلا لك من واشنطن جولدن السفير
الامريكيه السابق في تونس
معنا من تونس ايضا احمد الهمامي المتحدث
باسم تحالف احرار مرحبا بك سيد احمد
اعتقال المعارضين بهذا بهذا الشكل
وبالوتيره المتسارعه الى اي مدى يمكن ان
يخدم الرئيس قيس سعيد حتى في في الشارع
المؤيد له وخصوصا اننا تابعنا من يتحدث عن
اعتقالات خارج اطار الاجراءات القانونيه
المعمول بها والمتبعه في تونس
شكرا لك وتحيه لكافه المشاهدين الايقافات
التي تمت كلها قانونيه وعلى اجراءات
قانونيه ولا اظن ان الساده تحقيق يعني
يخطئون في الاجراءات القانونيه التي
اصدرها واريد الاشاره الى ان المعروفين
لعدهم او
قلت فعلا هم معارضون ولكن خلينا نتحدث
بالواقع التونسي الشعب التونسي يوم 25
جويليه وما قبل حتى 25 جويليه كان ينادي
بمحاسبه من اسد في البلاد ومن اجرم فيه
طيله عشيه سوداء اذا النتيجه ستكون
الموقوفين يكون سياسيين لا نستطيع ان نقف
او نساءل شخصا مارا في الطريق نقول له
تعالى لنحاسبك على ما في عشره سوداء
سيمكننا هناك سياسيين سيكونون هناك وزراء
سابقين حكومات البرلمانيين لانهم هم من
كانوا يقودون المرحله السياسيه في طله
عشريه سوداء ولكن منهم منهم منهم فقط
لانهم معارض للرئيس قيس سعيد
هذا ما يقوله هذا ما تقوله المعارضه
يجتمع
ون احتويات امرنا لاطاحه بالدوله واتاحه
بالقانون واتاحه برئيس الجمهوريه واداره
وهذه الاجتماعات في
تونس الى ملخص لها قانونيه وان لم توجد
لهم شبهه كبيره لما كان اصدر قاضي التحقيق
فيها هناك
في ق
ضايا شكرا تحدثت عن الايقافات ولكن
في
حاله شكرا لك واريد
الهمامي
شكرا جزيلا لك من تونس المتحدث باسم تحالف
احرار
نظمت في العاصمه التونسيه مسيره احتجاجا
على تعرض المهاجرين من دول افريقيه في
تونس لما وصف بتعامل عنصري من جانبها عبرت
وزاره الخارجيه التونسيه عن استغرابها
للبيان الصادر عن مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
بشان وضعيه الجاليه الافريقيه بتونس
بعض العنف كلمه او بها يبدا هذا بعض ما
تفعله كلمات التحريض
تعتقد جمعتنا انها ازمه خطيره لان طلابنا
يتعرضون لترهيب ذي طابع عنصري المضايقات
والاعتداءات مستمره في وسائل النقد العام
والشوارع كما يقدم الملاك على طردهم من
المنازل المستاجره
ان لذلك ان يتوقف يقول هؤلاء انهم حقوقيون
وناشطون تستهجن مسيرتهم في تونس العاصمه
ما بدا لهم خطاب رسميا عنصريا تجاه فئات
من المهاجرين جاءوا البلد مقيمين او
عامرين يصف المحتجون استهداف المهاجرين
الافارقه غير النظاميين بالعمل الفاشي
ويطالبون السلطات باستجابه الانسانيه
لتسويه اوضاع اعداد منهم
يعني
[موسيقى]
الى الحق الاقتصادي والاجتماعي باش يتمنى
انو يقوم طردهم ايضا من
الاماكن اللي يسكنوا فيها يمكن
اشخاص هنا في الشارع فما فما حملات امنيه
مكثفه
كانما فتحت هنا جبهه توتر جديده تونس في
غنى عنها نشطه اخيرا في الفضائيين الواقعي
والافتراضي حاله من التجاذب بينما يدعم
وجود طالب هجره افارقه من دول جنوب
الصحراء في تونس ومن يرفض توافدهم وبدا ان
الخطاب الخارج من قصر قرطاج زاد الامر
سوءا تحدث الرئيس قيس سعيد اخيرا عن ضروره
وضع حد لتدفق المهاجرين غير النظاميين من
دول افريقيا جنوبيه الصحراء الى البلاد
على وجه السرعه ولم يكن مفهوما وصفه وصول
اعداد كبيره منهم بانه مؤامره لتغيير
التركيبه الديموغرافيه في تونس
لم تتاخر ادانته مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
لتصريحات سعيد التي وصفتها بالعنصريه تجاه
مهاجرين افارقه في تونس
قالت في بيان انه جرى ابلاغ ممثل تونسي
بصدمه المفوضيه وقلقها من استهداف مواطنين
افارقه بغض النظر عن وضعهم القانوني في
البلاد هل تمت هنا ما اسيء فهمه ذاك ما
تراه الخارجيه التونسيه التي ترفض ما ورد
في بيان المفوضيه الافريقيه من عبارات
واتهامات قالت انه لا اساس لها من الصحه
واعتبرت الوزاره ان موقف المفوضيه بني على
فهم خاطئ لمواقف السلطات التونسيه
تصحيح اخر تنفيذ الداخليه التونسيه
الانباء عن حملات توقيف تستهدف المهاجرين
من دول افريقيا جنوبيه الصحراء وتدعو لعدم
الانسياق وراء ما تصفه بالمزايدات
والاتهامات التي تقوم بها جهات تحركها
اغراض مختلفه
لا تحدد تلك الجهات لكن الجهات الحقوقيه
والمدنيه في تونس تجمع على التنديد بخطاب
الكراهيه كما تصفه تجاه المهاجرين
الافارقه في حين ان جهات يمنيه متطرفه في
اوروبا التي يقصدها هؤلاء المهاجرون عاده
راقت لها تصريحات
قضيه المهاجرين الافارقه في تونس ستكون
محور فقره المتابعه بعد قليل وفيها نسال
عن الدوافع الحقيقيه لهذه الازمه وعن افاق
تجاوزها
[موسيقى]
اقر الاتحاد الاوروبي حزمه عاشره من
العقوبات على روسيا بالتزامن مع اعلان
الولايات المتحده عقوبات جديده عليها
وتشمل العقوبات الاوروبيه قيودا على تصدير
التكنولوجيا الدقيقه وقائمه جديده من
الافراد والكيانات ذات العلاقه بالحكومه
الروسيه تشمل مسؤولين وقاده عسكريين
تظاهر الالاف في العاصمه الالمانيه برلين
للمطالبه بوقت ارسال الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا
وباحياء المفاوضات مع روسيا رفع
المتظاهرون الذين خرجوا بالتزامن مع مرور
عام على حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا شعار
انهضوا من اجل السلام وبحسب شرطه
الالمانيه فقد شارك في المظاهره نحو عشره
الاف شخص
قال المستشار الالماني سن خطه السلام
الصينيه بشان الصراع في اوكرانيا تقدم
واضح للغايه واضاف جونس على هامش زيارته
للهند ان الخطه تستقر الى طلب واضح
لانسحاب القوات الروسيه
خطه السلام الصينيه بشان الصراعي في
اوكرانيا تقدم واضح للغايه هناك اشياء
صحيحه بشكل ملحوظ مثل الادانه المتجدده
لاستخدام الاسلحه النوويه وما تفتقده
الخطه هو الدعوه الواضحه الى انسحاب
القوات الروسيه من المهم ان تكون خطه
السلام الصينيه موجوده الان ولكن من المهم
ايضا ان نظن نجاحنا في تحقيق سلام عادل
ونزيه وليس سلاما بصياغه الروسيه وعلى
الرئيس الروسي ان يدرك ذلك ايضا
انتهت اعماله مجموعه العشرين في الهند دون
توصل الى توافق بشان الموقف من الحرب على
اوكرانيا وقد اعلنت الهند دعمها لموقف
مجموعه العشرين المطالب بانسحاب روسيا
الكامل وغير المشروط من اوكرانيا وفي بيان
صدر عقيبا انتهاء اجتماعي وزراء الماليه
ورؤساء البنوك المركزيه لدول مجموعه
العشرين اضافت الهند ان جميع دول المجموعه
صدقت على البيان الذي يندل بالحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا
باستثناء الصين وروسيا
[موسيقى]
علينا وزير العدل التركي جمع الادله من
نحو 8000 من المباني التي دمرها الزلزال
وتحدث عن حبس 184 شخصا بينهم 79 مقاولا
ضمن ملاحقه ومحاسبه المسؤولين عن سوء
تشييدها في هذه الاثناء قالت وحده تنسيق
الدعم في مناطق سيطره المعارضه السوريه ان
137 بلده ومدينه في شمال غرب سوريا تضررت
من الزلزال
تسترد تركيا وسوريا الانفاس تدريجيا بعد
كارثه زلزال السادس من فبراير الذي ضرب
مناطق منهما وتجاوز عدد قتلاه خمسين الفا
تتفاوت طموحات الفتره المقبله في البلدين
بالنظر لاختلاف السرعه والقدره على تجسيد
تلك الطموحات مع وضع الجوانب السياسيه في
الحسبان
السلطات التركيه تواصل حملتها الامنيه ضد
المقاولين الذين شيدوا الابنيه المتضرره
والمسؤولين عن تفتيش البنايات في مختلف
المناطق المنكوبه
وتجرى تحقيقات واسعه في هذا الاطار شملت
حتى الان 600 مشتبه فيهم واسفرت حسب وزير
العدل التركي بكير بوزداغ عن اعتقال عشرات
من بينهم رئيس بلديه نورداغ بولايه غاز
عنتاب التي لحقت بها اضرار كبيره جراء
الزلزال
وتقول الحكومه التركيه ان اعاده الاعمار
هي شغلها الشاغل في غمره تشابك خيوط كثيره
على راسها موعد الانتخابات المقرره في
الرابع عشر مما ينقبل وجدليه تاجيلها التي
تحتدم في الاوساط التركيه المختلفه
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان قال ان
بلاده تسعى لتشييد مباني جديده وامنه خلال
عام واحد لتعويض اصحاب المباني المتضرره
والتي بلغ عددها حتى الان 160 الفا وترد
انقره على الذين يدعون للتريث بان
المشاريع السكنيه الجديده ستراعى فيها
اقصى معايير السلامه وستبنى بعد الدراسات
دقيقه ووافيه لمختلف الاحتمالات
من ناحيه اخرى في سوريا كشف التعامل مع
الكارثه منذ البدايه عن تحديات في مجالات
الاغاثه والايواء بسبب الاوضاع المعقده
التي يعيشها الشمال السوري ظلت الامم
المتحده تؤكد الالتزام ببذل ما في وسعها
لصالح المنكوبين في شمال سوريا وتسعى
المنظمه الدوليه لجمع 400 مليون دولار
لتوفير الاغاثه العاجله للمتضررين لكن
المساعدات عبر الحدود تتخذ طابعا سياسيا
حيث تضغط الحكومه السوريه وحليفتها
الرئيسيه روسيا لصالح استراتيجياتها صحيح
ان الامم المتحده نجحت في فتح بعض المعابر
لاغاثه مناطق المعارضه المنكوبه بالاتفاق
مع دمشق لكن المنظمات العامله في المجال
الانساني تبحث عن معابر اضافيه ويدعو
بعضها لعدم انتظار موافقه النظام السوري
فالث انه حتى قبل
كانت تلك المناطق تعاني بؤسا شديدا ويعيش
غالبيه سكانها في مخيمات ويعتمدون على
المساعدات الانسانيه الشحيحه للبقاء على
قيد الحياه
معنى من ولاياتها في جنوب تركيا كرم قناق
رئيس الهلال الاحمر التركي ومن ريف حلب
معنا طارق حمد مدير مكتب جمعيه عطاء
للاغاثه الانسانيه في
جرابلس نبدا معك سيد كرم من ولايه هاتاي
والسؤال اليوم هو عن التحديات التي
تواجهونها بعد حوالي 20 يوما على هذا
الزلزال المدمر
التحدي الرئيسي الذي نعاني منه هو
التوفير المساعدات الاساسيه الانسانيه لكل
المتضررين وكل المناطق المتضرره في الوقت
ذاته
وحوالي اثنين فاصل خمسه او ثلاثه ملايين
شخص نقدم لهم الماوى والغذاء والخدمات
الاجتماعيه والطبيه والماء
والمواد التعقيم وايضا
مساعداته اخرى وذلك في في مساحه مئه الف
متر هل هذه
المواد او هذه المساعدات موجوده بوفره
وبما يكفي جميع المنكوبين والتحدي هو فقط
في نقلها دفعه واحده هل هي متوفره للجميع
في الوقت ذاتي هناك الكثير من نشاطات تجري
في وقت واحد من قبل مؤسسات الحكوميه
والمنظمات غير حكوميه والشركاء الدوليين
وان نحن مؤسستنا وتعمل بجد حوالي ثلاث
ملايين شخص نقلوا من مناطق المتضرره الى
محافظات القريبه وتقريبا
1.5 مليون شخص
جرائهم في خيمه مؤقته وحاويات
وهناك مناطق للنوم
وبناء ابنيه
فنادق صغيره
وكثير من هذه الكثير من
الكثير من المواطنين ايضا فتحوا منازلهم
للضحايا في
المحافظات القريبه والمحلات القريبه
وما زال
ما زال هناك
حاويات مؤقت
ومساكن مؤقته
تاتي الى المنطقه اما غذاء فهو تقريبا بدا
يصل للجميع ولكل مكان
ونحن كمجتمع تركي
ونحن نكون متطوعين
المسؤولين عن توفير التغذيه بشكل جماعي
وان شركاء ومع شركائنا نستطيع ان نقدم
طعام ل2
مليونين ونصف شخص وجوتي الطعام في اليوم
وهذا رقم كبير جدا وفي الوقت ذاته حوالي
400 الف خيمه في الواقع جرى نصبه هل هذا
هل هذا هل هذا الواقع هو نفسه في في
شمال سوريا هل هذا
ما يحصل سيد طارق حمد
حسن وحيه الله متابعي الجزيره الكرام
ومشاهديها طبعا اكيد تركيا دوله كبيره
وعندها امكانيات
امكانيه لا متناهيه لتقديم المساعدات
لشعبها والمصاب واحد بين سوريا وتركيا اما
الشمال السوري المنكوب الذي كان يعاني
لعشر سنوات من الحرب ومن القصف والتدمير
الممنهج من قبل نظام الاسد وقوات روسيا
وايران فهو بالاصل كان متعبا شديدا
الانهاك والان وبعد هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب
المنطقه والتراخي الشديد والتقاعس الكبير
الذي شاهدناه من الامم المتحده ومنظمات
الامميه في تقديم ومد يد العون وخصوصا في
الايام الاولى التي كانت كلها مصبه على
جهود الانقاذ كانت الكارثه كبيره وكانت
هذه واضحا وبينا لم يساهم اي مجهود دولي
او اي منظمه دوليه او اي من الشركاء
الدوليين في تقديم يد العون للشعب السوري
المكلوم كلكم يعني حجم الدمار الكبير وكما
سلفها في تقريباكم قبل قليل عشرات البلدات
تضررت الاف الشهداء قضوا تحت الالقاب الاف
الجرحى المشاكل التي تعانونها
وكيف تسير عمليات الاغاثه يعني تابعنا من
تركيا
يبدو ان الامور بدات تنتظم
والاغاثه بدات تصل الى الجميع على رغم كبر
الماسات
وهول الفاجعه لكن في سوريا الان اذا اردنا
ان نتحدث ما الذي يجري على الارض بعد يعني
ستمضي ثلاثه اسابيع بعد يومين
بعد عشرين يوما يعني يؤسفني ان اقول ان
جهود الاغاثه ما زالت خجوله وخجوله جدا
عندما نتحدث عن دخول بضع الشاحنات في
اليوم او تسيير حمله من هنا او قافله من
هنا طبعا انا اتوجه بالشكر الى كل من ساهم
وكل من ساهم وكل الجمعيات وكل الحملات
الاهليه في الداخل وفي الخارج كل ما قدم
يد العون الى الشعب السوري المكلوم اتوجه
اليهم بالشكر ولكن هذه قطره في بحر يعني
الكثير من الاحتياجات الان نحن بحاجه لها
سواء في الماوى في الاسكان في المجال
الصحي في المجال الخدمي يعني الان هناك
كنا نتحدث سابقا عن الوجود مليون شخص
يعيشون في المخيمات اضف اليهم الان عشرات
الالاف من العائلات التي فقدت سكنها اضف
اليهم الى الضغط النفسي التي تعرض له
الالاف من العائلات التي تتضررت مساكنها
بشكل جزئي هؤلاء الان لا يستطيعون العوده
حتى الى منازلهم وتلبيه احتياجاتهم
البسيطه كل هؤلاء الان بحاجه الى توفير
ماوى كريم يضمن لهم
عيشه كريمه حتى يتم الخروج من هذه الازمه
ايضا نحن الان في فصل الشتاء وهناك
احتياجات كبيره من
وقود التدفئه من مواد اغاثيه من تامين
البطانيات الحرامات الاسفنج ايضا القطاع
الصحي المتهالك الذي كان يعاني بالاساس من
الاستنزاف الكبير وحصل فيه استنزاف وايضا
بحاله بحاجه الى دعم كبير يعني نحن اساسا
نحتاج الى تعويض المخزون الدوائي الذي
فقدناه في الفتره الماضيه اكثر من ثمانيه
الاف جريح تمامه على المشافي السوريه
المتعبه المنهكه بحاجه الى مستلزمات جراحه
العظام اجهزه غسيل كلوي بحاجه الى الكثير
من الادويه الاوليه ادويه سكر الضغط ادويه
اطفال حليب اطفال يعني كل هذه احتياجات
كبيره لا يتم تلبيه جزء بسيط منها الحقيقه
نعم عذرا للمقاطعه يعني ربما الحديث لا
ينتهي لكن وقتنا هو الذي انتهى شكرا لك
طارق حمد من ريفي حلب مدير مكتب جمعيه
عطاء لغاز الانسانيه في جرابلس شكرا
رئيس الهلال الاحمر التركي من ولايتها تاي
المنكوبه
[موسيقى]
في نيجيريا كان الناخبون يوم السبت على
موعد مع مكاتب التصويت لانتخاب رئيس جديد
للبلاد واعضاء برلمانها
يبدا الناخبون المسجلون في هذه الانتخابات
الادلاء باصواتهم في هذه الانتخابات بعد
مطابقه بطاقتهم الانتخابيه والتاكد من
انهم مسجلون في هذه
المراكز الانتخابيه عبر هذه الاجهزه
الالكترونيه التي تحوي جميع اسماء
الناخبين وكذلك
بصماتهم ومن ثم يتم تسليم الذين تم التاكد
من بطاقاتهم والانتخابيه
تسليمهم لبطاقات الاقتراع من اجل التصويت
في هذه الانتخابات التي يتنافس فيها 18
مرشحا لمنصب الرئاسه والاف المرشحين
لمقاعد مجلس الشيوخ وكذلك البرلمان
ونشرت ونشرت مئات الالاف من قوات الامن من
اجل تامين هذه الانتخابات التي هدد
المسلحون من غوكو حرام وكذلك
الانفصاليون في جنوب شرق نيجيريا بعرقله
هذه الانتخابات
وبسبب الاعيادات الكبيره للنفط هذه السنه
يتوقع
المرشحون الفائز من المرشحين في هذه
الانتخابات الاستفاده من هذه العائدات
وتحقيق ما احد به للناخبين في هذه
الانتخابات فضل عبد الرزاق
[موسيقى]
على مدى ايام اثار التصريحات للرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد بشان المهاجرين الافارقه
جدلا وانتقادات في تونس وخارجيها فكيف
يبدو المشهد
تمثل تونس نقطه عبور لالاف المهاجرين
الوافدين من دول افريقيا جنوب الصحراء
الذين ينطلقون بعد ذلك في رحلات هجره
بحريه في اتجاه اوروبا خصوصا نحو ايطاليا
تمثل ولايه صفاقس الساحليه ذات الموقع
الجغرافي المتميز منصه رئيسيه لانطلاق
موجات الهجره نحو الاراضي الاوروبيه ومن
دول مثل ساحل العاج ومالي والكاميرون
وغانا وغينيا يوجد في تونس البالغ عدد
سكانها قرابه 12 مليونا اكثر من 21 الف
مهاجر بمن فيهم الطلبه والمقيمون بشكل
قانوني
لكن ماذا بعد تصريحات الرئيس التونسي على
بعد 20 كيلومترا شمال العاصمه التونسيه
اغلقت نهائيا صالونات الحلاقه والمطاعم
الافريقيه التي تم انشاؤها في السنوات
الاخيره واختفت الواجهات الملونه تحت
الطلاء الابيض
وكشف كثير من المهاجرين الافارقه في
الليالي الاخيره عن حرائق اضرمت اسفل
مباني او محاولات اقتحام منازل مواطنين في
تونس العاصمه المدينه التي يغادر منها
عشرات المهاجرين الى اوروبا
وقبل ايام من حديث الرئيس التونسي عن
ترتيب اجرامي تم اعداده منذ مطلع هذا
القرن لتغيير التركيبه السكانيه لتونس
نددت اكثر من 20 منظمه تونسيه حقوقيه
بمواصفته بخطاب كراهيه تجاه المهاجرين من
افريقيا جنوب الصحراء نستعرض ارقاما
لتوضيح المشهد
فقد اعلن المتحدث الرسمي باسم خفر السواحل
التونسي الاربعاء توطيف اكثر من 130
مهاجرا في مناطق مختلفه
وبحسب منظمات غير حكوميه تونس شهدت خلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين حمله اعتقالات شملت
مئات من المهاجرين افرجه عن معظمهم وفي
الثالث والعشرين من فبراير الجاريه قالت
صحيفه لوموند الفرنسيه ان عدد الافارقه في
تونس يقدرون بما بين ثلاثين وخمسين الفا
ومنذ اشهر تشير بيانات صادره عن الحرس
الوطني التونسي الى ضبط مئات المهاجرين
غير النظاميين من دول افريقيا جنوب
الصحراء قبل شروعهم في التوجه نحو اوروبا
عبر البحر المتوسط
معنى من تونس خوله بوكريم الناشطه
الحقوقيه ورئيس التحرير موقع كشف ميديا
مرحبا بك السيده خوله ما الذي اثار هذا
الموضوع بهذا الشكل يعني اذا نظرنا الى
الارقام الاعداد قياسا الى
عدد سكان تونس هي ارقام قليله جدا ولا لا
يمكن الحديث عن تغيير ديموغرافي يعني 30
الف في مقابل 12 مليون يعني الامر
لا يمكن مقارنته اذا لماذا تضخيم هذه
المشكله اليوم في تونس
مرحبا بك ومرحبا بكل مشاهدي شبكه الجزيره
طبعا لا يمكن فصل ملف الهجره غير النظاميه
عن الوضع الاقتصادي والاجتماعي وخاصه
السياسي في تونس كنتم تتحدثون عن ارقام
معينه باستطاعه ان امتكم باخر رقم يعني
نشرته محامون بلا حدود في تونس الرقم لا
يتجاوز 22 الف مهاجر اي 0.5% من المجموعه
السكان طبعا يعني هذا الوضع او هذا الخطاب
الذي انفجر ليس من من فراغ يعني اتحدث عن
خطاب رئيس الجمهوريه كانت هناك حملات
اعلاميه وحملات على صفحات مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مواليه لرئيس الجمهوريه قيس
سعيد منذ اكثر من سنه حول المهاجرين غير
النظاميين من افريقيا جنوب الصحراء حول
الافارقه حول
الافارقه اسود البشره هذه الحمله يعني
خطاب رئيس الجمهوريه هو تتويج بين ظفرين
لهذه الحمله وطبعا ليس ما يؤكدها سوى
الفشل الاقتصادي والاجتماعي لحكومه رئيس
الجمهوريه قيس سعيد للاسف نحن نعيش في خضم
اعتقالات سياسيه ثم فجاه نتحدث عن ملف
الافارقه لا يمكن باي حال من الاحوال ان
نفصل هذين الملفين لا يمكن تجنيس الجريمه
لا يمكن نسب الجريمه للون بشره بعينه لا
يمكن ان نقول ان الجريمه تقوم بها انثى
فقط او ذكر فقط اسود فقط ابيض فقط افريقي
تقولين انها محاوله للفت الانظار او حجب
الانظار عن المشكله التي تعيشها تونس
اليوم والمتمثله كان في الاعتقالات
المستمره والمتسعه
للمعارضين او الازمه الاقتصاديه التي
تعيشها البلاد طيب ما هي التداعيات يعني
اذا كان هذا الهوا هذا هو الهدف لكن
تداعيات على الارض تبدو خطيره جدا نعم
خطيره نحن نوثق حوادث عنصريه وكان
بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
الاربعينات والخمسينات يعني مهاجرين من
افارقه جنوب الصحراء يتم الهجوم على
بيوتهم تحرق اثاثهم يتم طردهم يعني لمن
يشاهدنا الان على شاشه الجزيره يعني
المهاجرين من افريقيا جنوب الصحراء هم
طلاب هم يعني الطلاب مدارس وطلاب جامعات
هناك من هم يعني ياتون لتونس لان لانهم
ذاقوا درعا من ويلات الحروب في افريقيا
يعني هم هاربون من جحيم الاصليق هاربون من
جحيم الحروب الاهليه هاربون من جحيم الجو
على الاستغلال الاقتصادي استغلال الثروات
كيف لتونس ارض الثوره 2011 الى الان 12
عاما ونحن نفتخر بهذه التجربه الديمقراطيه
ان يعني ان ننشر صوره قبيحه وسيئه جدا عنا
كتونسيين ونحن كتونسيون ما هو مصيرنا في
دول العالم وهو مصيرنا في اوروبا ما هو
مصيرنا في افريقيا يعني للاسف تونس
دبلوماسيتها الخارجيه لم تستثمر في عمقها
الافريقي وهنا نستطيع ان نستحضر المثال
المصري على رغم كل هنا النظام المصري لكنه
استثمر جيدا في عمقه الافريقي استثمارات
اقتصاديه واستثمارات يعني اجتماعيه كبيره
في افريقيا
يونس اليوم تروج لخطاب مخجل ومؤسف تونس
اليوم وكاننا نعيش في نعم انتهى وقتنا
عذرا سيده خوله ابو كريمه ناشطه الحقوقيه
ورئيسه تحذير موقع كشف ميديا من تونس
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا كل ما ذكرت ولايه كاليفورنيا
قفزت الى اذهان الجميع الشمس الساطعه
واشجار النخيل لكن الامر اختلف في الايام
الاخيره تهب على المنطقه احدى اشد العواصف
الشتويه منذ عقود عاصفه ثلجيه حول لوس
انجلوس لم يسبق لها مثيل بينما تهدد امطار
غزيره مناطق اخرى بالفيضانات اغلقت طرق
سريعه رئيسيه بسبب الجليد والثلوج مثل
اجزاء من طريق سريع يربط المكسيك
والولايات المتحده وكندا ومن غير المتوقع
اعاده فتحها قريبا
يصعب اقامه صله مباشره بين هذه العاصفه
وتغير المناخ لكن يؤكد العلماء باستمرار
ان الاحترار يزيد من تواتر وشده ظواهر
الطقس المتطرف
هي تداعيات للاحتباس الحراري تذكرنا مجددا
بعواقب ما يفعله البشر واهميه تكاتف جهود
الجميع لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه على كوكبنا
نواصل تغطيه الاخباريه بعد موجز رياضي مع
لؤي محمود